Do you happen to have a podcast discussing loyalty to marriage that involves
marriage to a service member?
I see many marriages,
military spouse,
where the service member has a great background in the military but lacks
marriage at home.
You know,
I actually have answered this question before and maybe not this specific,
but I'm going to go over it quickly just because this isn't just about military,
you know,
relationships,
it's about any relationship.
But you know,
from a military perspective,
absolutely military relationships are very hard.
You've got time away,
you got classified work,
there's a lack of understanding of what's going on at work.
Then you've got lives his deck,
right?
And with that,
the job has to come first and that's a very hard thing for people to understand
that the job has to come first.
Why does it have to come first for survival?
Because the harder you train,
the better you know your teammates,
the better shot you are,
the better your chance for actual survival in a combat situation.
So a spouse has got to understand that,
right?
That in order for the service member to take care of the family family,
this service member has to do his utmost to prepare himself and his team for
war.
The number one priority.
Now,
what the spouse has to understand is that this doesn't mean that he wants to
spend time away from his family.
He doesn't want to prioritize his team over his family.
He doesn't want to miss the recital,
doesn't want to miss the ball game,
doesn't want to miss the teacher's conference,
but he has to.
He has to.
So spouse,
don't be mad when he makes that priority
except an understand that the family is the number one priority.
It is the number one priority,
but in order to be there for the family,
he's got to prepare for war so that he can come home to his family after
deployment.
Now this,
this obviously also applies to police.
This applies to firefighters,
and I'll tell you what,
it applies really to the breadwinner,
man or wife,
husband or wife in any walk of life,
right?
If you're the breadwinner for the family,
you've,
that's what you're doing.
The way that you're taking care of the family is by bringing home money so that
there is food and housing and clothing and a secure future.
That's what you're doing.
And so the,
the spouse in these situations has to understand that the hard work,
the hard work and the hours and the days in the weeks that are taken away from
the family
is actually done to provide for the family.
Right?
So that's the key piece that people have to understand that the,
that the spouse has to understand.
Now the service member,
and again,
I've,
I've talked about this before,
the service member or the firefighter or the police officer or the breadwinner,
what they have to do is they have to make sure that they don't go overboard,
that they draw the line somewhere,
that they don't destroy what it is that you're trying to protect.
Don't destroy what it is you're trying to take care of.
Don't give the plants so much water that you drown it.
Don't cook the steak so long that you burn it.
Don't work so hard for your family that you don't have a family anymore.
You got to have the balance
in.
One of the things that you've got to do is you got to explain that to the family
and you've got to tell them what's up and you've got to tell them that they are
the more most important thing and that all this work that you're doing that's
taking you away from them is actually being done for them.
And you've got to communicate that to them.
They've got to understand it.
It's hard for them to listen to their heart.
For a a,
an eight year old kid,
don't understand why you're missing the,
the,
the baseball game or what the six year old girl,
while you're missing the digits,
who tournament or whatever.
It's hard to explain that,
but you've got to at least try.
You gotta make it evident them and you also have to make sure you don't abuse
it,
right?
Because work work can be fun and hanging out with our teammates for an extra day
of shooting or an extra day of jumping or having a beer at the pub on the way
home.
That can also sometimes be more appealing than the recital,
then the ballgame.
So don't abuse it.
Do you have to take care of your family and you have to talk to each other and
understand this balance together,
understand the sacrifices that are being made on both sides so that you can work
it out and maintain the strength of that entity,
the family that you're trying to take care of.